pour cette nouvelle année je veux
partager avec vous trois convictions la
première c'est que nous trouvons les
solutions aux prises actuelles dans le
dialogue et en demeurant un territoire
unique c'est une voie difficile
exigeante et dans ces temps agitée le
rassemblement des bonnes volontés mais
pas une option c'est une nécessité la
deuxième c'est le besoin impérieux de
proximité c'est ma conviction profonde
sans proximité il n'y a pas de confiance
et sur le départemental en est la plus
belle des représentations avec les
communes et les élus basent de notre
démocratie la dernière c'est que pour
accomplir de grandes choses il faut
sortir de la politique des certitudes au
bâtir une politique de projet une
politique du bon sens je ne conçois pas
l'action publique autrement
[Musique]